what is dark souls if not death a series
notorious for difficulty and a narrative
packed to the brim with grave themes
that will have some players looking at
the you died screen more than they
actually play the game
if you've never played the soulsborne
series look no further than chammi's
this is what dark souls 3 is like for a
quick familiarization
though in the endless comparisons of
other games to the series solely when
they include any semblance of difficulty
it's easy to be left with a reductive
view of the series and its use of death
a kind of hard for hardness sake
but the difficulty failure and focus on
death which one finds in a fromsoft game
is more than this it is a constitutive
piece of what makes a video game a work
of art failure in games helps to
demarcate them as an art form a form
filled with interactivity and engagement
unlike any other and even more so death
in the soulsborne is not just a gameplay
mechanic with the narrative introduction
of the hollow and the process of
halloween death takes on an essential
story element both in giving an in-game
explanation for the mechanic of
respawning and going beyond the game to
tell a story about us as players even
casting judgment on us deeming us hollow
if we fail to meet its mark this going
beyond at the confluence of gameplay and
narrative is where the soulsborne series
enters the ludo narrative and in doing
so shows off a unique aesthetic
experience only found in the video game
i want to explore all of this from
gameplay to story to player and all the
artistic in between as they are richly
presented to us in the concepts of death
and halloween in dark souls
plus it's halloween
as i look at death failure and halloween
in the soulsborne franchise i want to
make use of a really insightful piece of
writing a philosophy phd dissertation
from one zach jurgensen who wrote about
the artistic merit of games in his paper
titled the aesthetic value of video
games an analysis of interactivity
gameplay and player performance this
piece highlights a lot of unique and
important aspects of what makes games so
artistically meaningful a key element of
which being the fact that they are games
one of the ways that jurgensen details
that video games can provide unique
merit is how they can employ failure
firstly a game that is too easy is
simply not engaging jurgensen notes that
if a player is guaranteed success
without the threat of failure then
engagement with the game turns into
manipulation as opposed to interaction
he goes on to cite research which finds
players enjoying games more when they
occasionally fail as opposed to when
failure is completely absent for it to
be a game there has to be some chance
you lose if there isn't then the
developer risks the player becoming
disengaged and according to jurgensen
the potential for a unique aesthetic
experience found through interactivity
and immersion is lost
and in his next statement much to the
glee of die hard no easy mode allowed
souls fans jurgensen concludes games
that are too easy or require little
attention to rules of skill fail to take
full advantage of what sets video games
apart from other artistic mediums the
potential for a highly immersive
interactive experience easy games negate
the value of working within the video
game medium
now even with these statements there is
plenty of room for people to argue about
whether or not soulsborne games still
need to be as hard as they are or if you
like to be special that they actually
aren't that hard at all and definitely
need to be harder i'm not here to weigh
in too much on the details either way
but i do want to say that the presence
of this difficulty this guarantee of
failure is to a large degree absolutely
necessary
it becomes a vital component of the
experience of the game failure is one of
the variables that interactivity and
engagement are most dependent on to
really experience what a video game is
this engagement and thus this failure
must be there
and it must be there in the right manner
pulling from another writer jesper
jewell jurgensen spends half of his
discussion on failure describing how it
has to be the right kind of failure
failure caused by user action
unsurprisingly we find a good example of
this right kind in dark souls a series
notorious save for a few notable
exceptions for being fair with its
deaths and causes of failure if you die
in dark souls most of the time it's on
you whether that be for rushing in or
not taking the time to note irrelevant
detail while they certainly don't have a
perfect track record fromsoft games
generally embody this right kind of
failure pretty well keeping the player
engaged by having their failure
determined by their own actions when
jurgensen says that easy games negate
the value of working within the medium
he is saying that ease completely fails
to utilize one of the core aspects that
demarcate games from other media easy
games can of course still exist not
every game has to flaunt how different
it is from movies and books and the like
plus there are plenty of relatively
chill games that might be thought of as
easy but still have a decent amount of
failure stardew valley comes to mind
however in discussions of the medium of
games and how it can grow and develop
and deliver the artistic experiences
that help make life worth living the
presence and mechanic of failure must be
included
but as i said death in dark souls is not
just a gameplay mechanic it is also a
prominent narrative theme permeating the
game world and especially the differing
game endings and importantly it's the
path to becoming hollow hollowness in
dark souls is essentially the
destruction of the mind in the in-game
story a curse has afflicted the land
preventing those who contract it from
dying most of these undead eventually
lose their minds and become hostile
zombie-like figures they have gone
hollow
your character in dark souls 1 the
chosen undead is one of these undead who
is to some degree hollow narratively
this explains and justifies why the
player character can respond after death
instead of just accepting the logical
inconsistency of dying and re-trying to
fight two seconds later i say two
seconds as if fromsoft would ever give
us a boss run back that isn't at least a
minute long the game justifies why the
failure of death is not permanent the
player character is undead so if they
fail a fight and die they just come back
to life to fight again and while this
exact kind of halloween isn't nominally
present in every game of the series at
least in the same ways there is
generally a similar ludonarrative theme
throughout
in the original dark souls after an
in-game death the player character gains
the appearance of a hollow a living set
of skin and bones and this halloween
also comes with some gameplay
restrictions but if the player continues
to play the game the player character
does not quite go hollow per se
throughout the game and the rest of the
series we realize that going hollow
happens chiefly with the loss of purpose
direction or meaning crestfallen
characters that lose hope and give up on
living admittedly undead living but
living nonetheless go hollow but the
player character doesn't as long as the
player keeps playing
and as the player keeps playing and
dying along comes another more meta
experience characteristic of dark souls
getting fed up with the game and its
deaths and giving up leaving the game
before you complete or beat its
narrative journey i know this experience
well as it was me when i came across the
first real boss of the game i must have
given up on dark souls 1 between 3 and 8
times when trying to best the taurus
demon the first boss after the tutorial
while there were some issues that i
would classify now as the bad kind of
failure referenced earlier failure that
did not have to do with my actions per
se or aspects of failure that did not
feel like they fit the crime boston
backs i died a lot and i wanted to give
up
and i did many times but i came back
each time sometimes after months and
eventually found out how to cheese the
boss and got through it in terminology
familiar to the game and the community
of fans i almost went hollow not just my
in-game avatar or character but me the
player when other players leave messages
in the game world or non-player
characters speak to your character and
they say not to give up hope and not to
go hollow they may be directed first to
the in-game character but as that
character's controller they then address
you the player when a player gives up on
the game without fighting to the end and
choosing that final fate to link the
flame or let it go out or something
subsequent in the later games they are
leaving their character as one of the
mindless drones to sit in the universe
of the game forever aimless and without
purpose
hollow
in this connection of gameplay to story
and metagame play to story two core
elements of the video game are being
fused this is the ludo narrative a term
made popular by the concept of
ludonarrative dissonance but a more
broad phenomenon that describes the
interplay of gameplay as ludus is the
latin word for game and narrative within
video games jurgensen discusses this
concept of ludonarrative albeit in
different terms as another core aspect
of video game aesthetics while jurgensen
uses the example of braid i think his
discussion is just as applicable to dark
souls he says with a bit of my own
subject interjection to make the quote
work by connecting the mechanics of
death failure and respawning with the
story element of halloween dark souls
successfully connects its game hood with
the narrative taking full advantage of
the interactivity video games offer
doing so creates a cohesive object of
aesthetic appreciation where the
artistic value of the narrative and
gamehood are intimately intertwined
to me this connection of gamehood and
narrative to create a unique aesthetic
experience is one of if not the core
artistic merits of video games it is a
blend of aesthetic in a medium specific
way no other kind of art could deliver
an experience of the same kind
as such to see it happen in dark souls
especially in tandem with another vital
gaming experience that of failure is to
witness and recognize a profound moment
of artistic depth
with so much tied up into a single
mechanic so much player experience and
narrative weight which is able to reach
out from the game and comment on even
judge the player themself it is clear
that a deeply artistic and aesthetically
worthwhile experience resides here at
the confluence of death and halloween in
dark souls
i really wanted to get this video out on
halloween for the title pun and i also
really want to discuss the aspect of
ludo narrative and the philosophy of
games more both how video games achieve
unique artistic status and how they can
relay traditional philosophical
knowledge hopefully this is a good
primer that you my audience will be
receptive to as it has been dark souls
centric i'm hoping to do a follow-up
video that focuses on the ludo narrative
more centrally and explores these
concepts more explicitly
well those are my closing remarks and i
hope you enjoyed the video be sure to
stick around if you want more of this
kind of content thanks